you're in a thruple which is a
polyamorous none of the three of us had
had this type of relationship experience
before I don't think we were willing to
allow in the reality that what we were
feeling below the surface was romantic
interest right especially Loi and I were
in a commit it we were married at that
time we're in a commit it what we
thought was going to be monogamous
relationship and now kind of we're
getting this internal interest in this
third person there was several months
where so much of this was below the
surface again just to use the language
of the book where we weren't really
attuning to what it was that our heart
was wanting that was translating into a
lot of conflict and a lot of tension in
the relationship now of course I share
that to say that you know listeners I
don't think it always translates to
expanding your relationship in this new
Direction though I think there are so
many moments Dana where we have these
things that we want to say that we want
to get out our chest that we want to
express and we don't for whatever reason
in our
relationship